RIGHT,
HERE WE GO. WE'RE WORTH
THERE WERE QUESTIONS HERE AND
NOW THEY'RE GONE. WELL, YOU
MUST IMPRESS. I GUESS NOT THEM
DOWN.
NO, I GUESS I KNOW SOMETHING
HAPPENED. THEY WERE HERE AND
NOW THEY'RE GONE. SO I'LL GO
TO THE ONE THAT I DIDN'T THINK
WAS GOING TO BE THE FIRST ONE.
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING AT
PLAYOFF CAP WHICH
FRANCHISE WINNING THE SUPER
BOWL WOULD BE THE MOST
LEGENDARY.
THIS IS A QUESTION FROM
PLAYOFF CAP, WHICH
FRANCHISE WINNING THE SUPER
BOWL FOR THE FIRST TIME WOULD
BE THE MOST LEGENDARY
PLAYOFF CAP THINKS IT'S
ATLANTA
DUE TO THEIR CURSE IN BIG
GAMES. WHO DO YOU THINK IT
WOULD BE ATLANTA'S UP
THERE BUT
I THINK THE CLEVELAND BROWNS
ARE THE OBVIOUS ANSWER TO ME,
RIGHT? I MEAN, IT JUST AGAIN,
THEY HAVE A FAN BASE AND A
AND A HISTORY
THAT'S TOP-NOTCH. I MEAN, THEY
HAVE A HISTORY THAT WILL RIVAL
JUST ABOUT ANYBODY
IN THE HISTORY OF
BALL,
YOU KNOW,
PRE 1990S. BUT AFTER THAT,
IT'S JUST BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
CRAP SHOW. SO YEAH, I'M GOING
WITH THE THE CLEVELAND BROWNS
THERE. WHAT ABOUT YOU'RE GOING
THEM
TO? YEAH,
I'D SAY THE BROWNS. I MEAN
LOOK THE VIKINGS HAD FOUR
CHANCES. THE BILLS HAD
FOUR CHANCES.
THE BROWNS HAVE NEVER EVEN
BEEN TO THE SUPER BOWL. SO
I THINK THAT GIVEN
HOW
BAD THEY WERE JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO,
ESPECIALLY IF THEY WOULD WIN
IT THIS YEAR.
YES. THAT WOULD BE
THAT.
IT WOULD BE GIGANTIC WHO
SET THEM ON THAT LIST TO YOU
IT FOR
WHO'S THE NEXT ONE? LIKE ARE
YOU
IS IT - LIKE BUFFALOES THE
OTHER ONE THAT COMES TO MY
BRAIN A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE OF
LIKE YOUR SAME THING WITH YOUR
VIKINGS LIKE THE
FOR SUPER BOWL
LOSSES IS SUCH A
UNBELIEVABLE
GOOD THING AND A BAD THING
THAT, YOU KNOW, YEAH, I'D LIKE
TO SEE THEM GET ONE AT ONE
POINT.
YEAH, I
THINK THE BILLS HAVE A TEAM
THAT IS
BETTER SUITED TO DOING IT. I
JUST ACCEPTED THE FACT
THAT THE VIKINGS NEVER WILL
THEY JUST I KNOW
IN THE CORE OF MY
BEING
THAT THEY NEVER WILL
THOUGH ALWAYS KIND OF HOVER
BUT THEY'LL NEVER LAND THE
PLANE. AND THAT'S JUST THE WAY
IT IS. ALL RIGHT, THIS IS A
NICE PURPLE SHIRT. YOU GOT
FROM
420 ON TOP. WELL, THAT'S JUST
I LIKE THE SHIRT
FOR 20 ONTOLOGY, WHICH MEMBERS
OF THE BUCCANEERS TEAM.
/.
OFFICE
MATCH TO EACH CHARACTER
IN THE MOVIE GOODFELLAS
NAME AS MANY AS YOU CAN.
IN 30
SECONDS. WELL, THAT'S ACTUALLY
PUT A LITTLE THOUGHT INTO
THIS. DO YOU HAVE ANY, DO YOU
HAVE ANY? YOU WANNA HEAR MY?
I WANT TO HEAR YOURS FIRST. GO
AHEAD
AND LET ME LOOK AT THE FRONT
OFFICE DO AS WE DO THIS. GO
AHEAD. ALL RIGHT, WELL,
I'M
STARTING
MAINLY WITH PLAYERS. I GOT
PLAYERS AND A COACH, RIGHT?
AND I'VE ONLY GOT A FEW OF
THEM, BUT THESE ARE THE ONES
THAT CAME TO MIND.
MIKE EVANS IS HENRY HILL
BECAUSE HE'S SO QUIET, HE
NEVER TALKS
ACCORDING TO
TOMMY'S MOTHER. THAT'S THE
PERFECT MATCH. THEIR OTHER
THAN THAT, I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING
HENRY.
YEAH.
TELL HE'S SO QUIET. YOU NEVER
TELL SHUT UP.
ALWAYS TALKING.
JIMMY CONWAY IS TOM BRADY
BECAUSE HE'S JUST LIKE THE
MASTERMIND. HE'S IN CHARGE OF
EVERYTHING,
RIGHT? THE GUY THAT RUNS THE
SHOW, RIGHT? ANTONIO BROWN
IS TOMMY BECAUSE HE'S A BAD
SEED, ALTHOUGH HE HAS REFORMED
HIMSELF A LITTLE BIT. TOMMY,
NEVER GOT THAT CHANCE BECAUSE
HE GOT WHACKED THE DAY, HE
THOUGHT HE WAS BEING MADE.
ANTONIO BROWN ACTUALLY GOT
MADE, HE GOT HIS SUPER BOWL,
HE DIDN'T GET SHOT IN THE
BASEMENT, INSTEAD,
THAT'S KIND OF MORBID,
AND
RUSEV
HAS GOT TO BE PAUL. HE'S
RIGHT. NO, NO, I THINK BRUCE
ARIANS IS MORRIS BECAUSE HE
NEVER SHUTS UP,
MAN. MORRIS.
IT'S SOAKED OUT
UNTIL THAT'S NOT COOL.
AND I THINK HE'S MO OTHE
BOSS. LIKE THEY GO, THE
BRADY AND ALL THEM. THEY GO TO
BRUISED AREAS TO MAKE SURE
LIKE CAN WE CALL THIS
PLAY AND HE'S LIKE,
YOU KNOW, DON'T DO THAT
PLAY, DON'T EMBARRASS ME OR
WHATEVER HE SAYS IN THAT LINE
AND YOU KNOW, WHATEVER THAT'S
HE THAT'S TO BRUCE ARIANS
THAT'S IT. WAS THAT HIS NAME?
I CAN'T REMEMBER. IT
IS TO POLY YA. YA POLY
POLY. THEY'RE ALL PAULIE, THEY
ARE
ALL HERE. HOW DARE YOU SAY
THAT?
IT'S A GREAT MATCH BODY LIKE
THEY WENT WITH THAT.
I LIKE THAT LITTLE QUESTION
THERE. THAT WAS A GOOD
ONE. DO YOU HAVE ANY ANY OTHER
CHARACTERS YOU WANT TO JAM IN?
WHO WOULD YOU BE THE FORMER?
BECAUSE YOU USED TO BE IN THE
CREW USED TO BE IN THE
BUCCANEERS CROW. I KNOW, I
DON'T THINK
AS YOU BID ON. THINK I MAKE IS
THERE.
MAYBE I'M I'M THE GUY THAT
SHOWS UP WITH THE PINK
CADILLAC IN THE
THE MINK.
THAT'S HIS NAME, THE
MAIN CODE AND THE CADILLAC.
OR NO, YOU'RE DEFINITELY NOT
JIMMY
TWO TIMES BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
LOSE YOUR SPLEEN TO TIME.
NO,
NO ACTUALLY I CAN'T SPEAK
RIGHT.
THE FIRST TIME TO SAY
THAT THE SECOND TIME, SO I'M
NOT HIM EITHER.
I DON'T THINK I MADE IT TO THE
RIGHT
WILL BE TONS SQUAD
42. WHY HAVEN'T THE VIKINGS
GONE OUT AND ADDED A THIRD?
THIRD RECEIVER, THERE HAS TO
BE A BETTER OPTION THAN CHAD
BB OR BC JOHNSON. THEY LOVED
BC JOHNSON. NOT THAT LONG AGO.
HE HASN'T REALLY DEVELOPED
INTO THE GUY THAT THEY THOUGHT
HE WOULD BE. THEY LIKE CHAD
BABY LOOK BUT REALLY BEHIND
JUSTIN JEFFERSON AND
ADAM THIELEN. THERE IS A
DROP OFF. AND YOU KNOW,
NOT THAT LONG AGO PATRICK
PATRICK PETERSON WHO'S NOW.
WITH THE VIKINGS SAID, IF
LARRY FITZGERALD
ISN'T RETIRED, NOW HE'S NOT
RETIRED AND I FEEL LIKE
LARRY FITZGERALD IS WAITING
FOR SOMETHING. HE'S WAITING.
MAYBE TO SEE
WHO DECLARES THEMSELVES AS
HIGH-END CONTENDERS AND HIS
DAD. LARRY FITZGERALD, SENIOR
LONGTIME SPORTS WRITER IN
MINNESOTA SAID,
IT'S NOW BEEN 10 YEARS AGO,
LARRY FITZGERALD,
WHO WAS BY THE WAY, A BALL BOY
FOR THE 1998 TEAM WITH
RANDY MOSS, CHRIS CARTER ETC.
THAT
WENT 15 AND 1 LARRY
FITZGERALD. SENIOR SAID
THAT
HIS SON IS A
VIKING AND ALWAYS WILL BE A
VIKING.
AND
AGAIN IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE I
THINK THE VIKINGS TO COME OUT
OF THE GATES HOT. I DON'T
THINK HE'S GONNA WANT TO LIMIT
HIS OPTIONS.
I THINK HE'S A FREE AGENT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO JUMP
THROUGH ANY HOOPS. HE CAN WAIT
UNTIL THE WEEK OF THE SUPER
BOWL IN SAN WITH SOMEONE IF HE
WANTS TO. YEAH, BUT I THINK
HE'S DETERMINED TO GET A RING.
AND I THINK HE'S GOING TO WAIT
AND HE'S GOING TO WAIT, HE'S
NOT GOING TO SAY A WORD,
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO HEAR
ANYTHING FROM HIM. THERE'S NO
DEADLINE. THAT APPLIES, HE CAN
SIGN WITH ANYONE AT
ANY TIME
MAYBE
KIND OF
UNOFFICIALLY HOLDING A SPOT
IN THE EVENT THAT FITZGERALD
DECIDES BY.
I DON'T KNOW MIDDLE OF
OCTOBER.
YEAH. YOU KNOW WHAT, THIS TEAM
IS GOOD ENOUGH THIS YEAR,
MAYBE THEY DO HAVE A SHOT,
I'LL COME HOME FOR ONE MORE
YEAR, RIGHT? AND SEE IF I CAN
BE THE DIFFERENCE MAKER
II MEAN, I DON'T THINK THAT'S
CRAZY
POSSIBILITY. I MEAN, I AM
INTERESTED TO
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WITH LARRY
FITZGERALD.
YOU KNOW? I REALLY AM.
I MEAN, IT'S KIND OF FUNNY.
WE'VE HEARD NOTHING,
YOU KNOW, HERE.
I MEAN, NOT A RUMOR.
NOTHING AT ALL.
I THOUGHT THE BUCCANEERS AT
ONE POINT, BUT BUT THEY HAVE
ABSOLUTELY,
NO NEED. THEY WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE AN INJURY. YEAH, THAT'S
RIGHT. OR IT'S LIKE UNTIL
BROWNED AND COME BACK. MAYBE
THAT'S WHERE HE WOULD HAVE
FILLED THAT VOID OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. I MEAN, THAT MAKES
SENSE. BUT LIKE, HEY,
I WANT TO GET TO THAT QUESTION
FROM OUR TOON SQUAD 42.
WHAT ABOUT THE THIRD RECEIVER?
YOU KNOW, LISTEN CERTAINLY YOU
COULD MAKE THE CASE TO MAYBE
YOU'D WANT SOMEBODY A LITTLE
MORE PROVEN
OR BETTER, WHATEVER THAT IS.
BUT ALSO
ALSO THIS
THE REASON THEY DON'T HAVE A
BIG-TIME THIRD
RECEIVERS YOUR TEAM, IS THERE
A
21 FOOTBALL TEAM, YOU KNOW,
AND I MEAN THAT
21 PERSONNEL. IT'S
TWO BACKS. ONE, TIGHT END,
TWO RECEIVERS THAT'S HOW THEY
PLAY. THEY DON'T REALLY WANT
TO GET IN FIRST AND SECOND
DOWN INTO THREE RECEIVER SETS
AND DO THAT TYPE OF STUFF. SO,
BECAUSE OF THAT, THAT'S WHY
THEY PROBABLY LOOK FOR,
YOU KNOW,
VALUES AT THE THIRD RECEIVER
POSITION,
THEY REALLY THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT EVERYBODY GETTING THE
BALL. THEY WANT THE BALL
ENDOWMENT COOKS AND AND
JEFFERSON'S HAND.
AND FEELIN'S HAND AND
EARTH'S MISS HAN. AND THAT
PECKING ORDER I BELIEVE NOW
THAT IS OFFICIALLY GONE AND
WITHIN
21 PERSONNEL THE KUBIAK
SHANAHAN SCHEME. THAT'S WHAT
THEY DO AND THAT'S WHY I DON'T
THINK THEY'LL EVER SPEND A LOT
OF MONEY AS LONG AS THAT
OFFENSIVE SCHEME IS THERE ON
THE THIRD RECEIVER.
BUT YOU STILL NEED TO HAVE
SKEWED OCEAN. DEFINITELY, NO
DOUBT BEYOND. AND I'M LOOKING,
I'M LOOKING AT THE
DEPTH CHART. NOW I'M LOOKING
AT THE NAMES, NOT THE DEPTH
CHART PER SE BUT JUST THE
NAMES OF RECEIVERS IN THERE,
THERE ARE NONE THAT JUMP OUT.
I KNOW, CHAD BB HAS DONE SOME
GOOD THINGS.
THEY
DID LIKE BC JOHNSON A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. HE'S GOT
SOME POTENTIAL BUT THERE'S A
BIG DROP FROM
JUSTIN JEFFERSON AND ADAM
THIELEN TO WHOEVER ELSE IS
THERE AND THEY BETTER HOPE
THEY KEEP THE TOP TWO HEALTHY.
ALRIGHT LAST QUESTION VERY
IMPORTANT ONE FROM
1980 BILLS FAN WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF BRANDON BEANS CALVES?
AND THE PHOTO IS
IMPRESSIVE. I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE CAN CONFIRM WITH A HUNDRED
PERCENT CERTAINTY THAT THOSE
ARE BRANDON BEANS CALVES.
FIRST OF ALL,
IT'S A LITTLE
SASQUATCHY WITH THAT THICKET
OF HAIR ON THEM BUT
SECOND OF ALL GOOD. LORD.
LORD. YEAH, THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S A THIGH MUSCLE THAT GOT
ATTACHED TO A LOWER LEG. I
THINK THAT'S A SHADOW. I DON'T
THINK THAT'S LIKE ALL HAIR
THERE. I DON'T THINK HE'S. SO
I SEE THIS HAIR.
THERE'S NO, I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT.
I KNOW THAT THERE'S JUST
ONE IS SHADOW AND
HAIR. CHRIS, HE'S GOT
VERY HAIRY LOWER LEG,
OKAY, THANK YOU. DOCTOR,
THEY ARE IMPRESSIVE. CALF
MUSCLES. THEY ARE.
AND, I MEAN, THERE'S, THERE'S
SOME REAL MUSCLE THERE. THERE
IS. NOW IT'S,
THAT'S NOT LIKE, THAT'S SOME
POWER CALF MUSCLES. ALL RIGHT.
RIGHT? THAT'S NOT A
BEAD CALF MUSCLE.
NO, NO
RECEIVER OR A RUNNING BACK
TO HAVE A CALF MUSCLE. THAT
GOES THAT FAR DOWN
AND ALMOST GETS TO THE ANKLE
RIGHT? THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
LIKE
THAT CALF MUSCLE. THAT'S LIKE
A TINY LITTLE BALL,
REALLY HIGH UP TOWARDS THE
BACK OF THEIR KNEE CAP AND
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
ACHILLES TENDON THAT SAID THIS
LONG AND THAT'S WHY THEY CAN
RUN AND JUMP THROUGH THE ROOF
ARE LIKE A REAL ATHLETIC WIDE
RECEIVER DB TYPE OF GUY.
SO BRANDON
BEING HE'S GOT SOME POWER
THERE. I LIKE THAT PRETTY GOOD
DEFINITELY GONNA BE
UP THERE.
MUCH.
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH YOU CAN
DO TO BUILD A CALF MUSCLE,
MUCH OF IT IS JUST IT EITHER
IS OR IT ISN'T RIGHT? YES,
YES. THERE'S THERE'S SOME
WE COULD PROBABLY LOOK AT A
GUY. LIKE LET'S JUST SAY ODELL
BECKHAM JR.
AND YOU'D PROBABLY BE
UNDERWHELMED ABOUT THE SIZE OF
HIS CALF MUSCLE A LITTLE BIT.
HE COULD DO 90 MILLION
CALF RAISES A DAY. IT'S NOT
GOING TO GET MUCH BIGGER. IT
JUST GOING TO GET STRONGER AND
TIGHTER AND MAYBE THAT WAY. O M
BUT YEAH, TH